je
sophie dostaler securitas allures de
blizzard
mesdames et messieurs le niveau dit le
secrétaire du conseil de sécurité
la fédération de russie général de
l'eure mais bonjour chers collègues je
suis ravi de s'élever à la 9e conférence
de moscou sur la sécurité internationale
c'est tout à fait symbolique et que
notre rencontre se passe juste après le
400e anniversaire de l'attaqué de
l'allemagne nazie contre la russie la
russie l'ayant soviétique ayant
contribué largement à la victoire à la
seconde guerre mondiale
cependant ce contre des tentatives de
déformer l'histoire on connaît très bien
que ceux qui oublient les leçons de
l'histoire seront forcés de les revivre
et non pas sur les pages des manuels
d'histoire mais dans la vie réelle
il faut que s'en souviennent ceux qui
s'efforcent aujourd'hui de donner la
renaissance à l'idéologie nazie en
proclamant les fascistes en tant que des
libérateurs de l'europe contre la menace
orientale durant des centenaire de son
histoire la russie à assumer la mission
noble civilisationnel en libérant
l'europe du nazisme nazisme notre api a
joué un grand rôle à la libération du
joug colonial
les peuples africains nous avons
toujours répondu présent aux demandes de
nos partenaires et nos amis des dizaines
de fois nous avons à donner de
l'assistance volontaire au pays aspirant
à l'indépendance en 1960 au poids
l'empiré russe a aidé les états unis à
[Musique]
comploter pour leur intégrité
territoriale au moins trois fois nous
avons aidé les français a lutté pour
l'heure ce ver n'était je pense qu'on
aurait du mal à trouver en pays qui n'a
jamais reçu de l'aide de la part de la
russie a pour protéger sa souveraineté
on trouve but de nombreux pays dans le
monde entier qui ont reçu cette
assistance
alors je vais pas exagérer si je dis que
l'aspiration à en ordre mondial s'en
sert et égal et sans entendre la voix de
tous les acteurs non obstant de leur
place à l'échiquier international et
restant très important de la politique
extérieure de la rue de dole et russie
qui reste intacte et pendant des siècles
de notre histoire
c'était le cas le temps de lempire russe
le temps de l'union soviétique
ça reste le cas maintenant nous laissons
ce majeur personnes sans aide personne
qui le demande
pour le prouver on peut citer la
contribution au massive mais russe à la
lutte contre le terrorisme en république
et syrienne à la demande du gouvernement
légitime du pays
la russie a envoyé un contingent
militaire
le moment le plus dur de l'histoire
syrienne en combattant coup de coude
avec
les troupes syriennes contre les
terroristes nous avons su le faire
repousser et renoncer à leur projet de
cris rallyes passés sur le territoire de
plusieurs pays asiatiques
nos militaires ont lutté non seulement
pour l'avenir si riant mais pour
l'avenir de notre monde
il est déplorable que certains pays à
prétendants d'être des grandes
puissances n'ont pas voulu faire front
commun contre ce fléau contemporain mais
au contraire se sont efforcés à rendre
notre lutte plus difficile la russie
actuellement aide à la syrie à restaurer
ce nikon émis à restaurer ce need a
assuré le retour des réfugiés et les
leur intégration dans la vie ordinaire
nous envoyons de l'aide humanitaire
nous aidons à reconstruire l'économie la
santé publique
le système d'éducation notre pays a très
bien appris la leçon que le terrorisme
doit être irradie qui y compris ses
racines la pauvreté à la fragilité
sociale l'illettrisme alors actuellement
on continue à construire des hôpitaux et
des écoles sur le territoire syrien
en prolongeant cette lutte qui a été
commencé par nos militaires
nous voyons des premiers du terrorisme
international à notre vecteur la
dégradation de la situation en
afghanistan qui progresse au fur et à
mesure de la sortie des contingents
américains et de l'otan ce qui
renforcera l'activité terroriste du des
shs et d'al qaïda dans le pays
base de ressources puissantes sera
assurée par le trafic des stupéfiants
dont les volumes ont connu une
augmentation d'une quarantaine de fois
durant le séjour du contingent
occidentale sur le territoire afghan en
souffrance est beau nous nous basons à
ce que les états unis et le temps
respecteront leurs promesses à aider
financièrement est le gouvernement
avions nous attendons qu'ils aident les
forces du maintien de l'ordre afghanes
et aideront à résoudre d'autres
problèmes à important nous croyons
inadmissible d'utiliser le problème
afghan a en tant qu une nuit hier pour
résoudre les problèmes jeu politique et
y compris pour justifier la présence des
acteurs extra régionale dans l'asie
centrale l'asie se prononce pour le
lancement d'un dialogue direct
argan avec à long terme et avec la
médiation des partenaires étrangers en
utilisant y compris le ferment du moose
coût des consultations sur l'afghanistan
un autre au no aspirons à utiliser plus
profondément le potentiel des mécanismes
de coopération à en ligne de
l'organisation de sécurité de shanghai
du traité de sécurité collective n'est
autre est la lutte contre la menace
terroriste en libye ne doit pas être
sous-estimé en 6 que cette lutte dans
toutes les régions de celle de serre
il faut se rappeler que le terrorisme ne
surgit pas de lui même
souvent c'est ce sont les conséquences
des expérimentés politique de certains
acteurs qui utilise volontairement des
terroristes de toutes sortes pour miner
la sévérité des paysans dépendants et
prennent la lutte contre le terrorisme
comme moi en prétextant ionel pourra
renforcer leur présence dans la région
désirer chers collègues à ces derniers
années on voit de plus en plus utilisé
des méthodes de guerre hybride qui
souvent sont même plus désastreuse que
les conflits traditionnels ni chaude
nous en avons des de multiples exemples
en ukraine en 2014 et les forces
externes ont misé sur les néo nazis pour
renverser le gouvernement légitime
aujourd'hui nous les voyons dicter leurs
volontés au gouvernement et même fonds
des intrusions à des territoires à
annexes
on en a trouvé des racines en
biélorussie dans ce pays il n'ya pas
longtemps on a su en ternir une
révolution de couleur
certains états étrangers ont franchi
toutes les lignes rouges ont leurs
tentatives des mines et leur à
l'activité du gouvernement légitime en
les remplaçant par leurs alliés
il s'agit tout d'abord d'un attentat
préparé par les citoyen américain contre
le président lieu de russes loukachenko
des attaques massives
faisant appel à des moyens de la lutte
en formation elle avec les pressions
externes au niveau à militaires
diplomatiques et économiques sont
réalisés contre d'autres pays
y compris le venezuela nicaragua et
certains pays de l'afrique et d'asie et
du moyen orient l'ingérence rude aux
affaires antérieures en vue de
déstabiliser la situation antérieure et
réalisé contre les a's états membres de
l'organisation de sécurité de shanghai
et de brix pour le thé contre d opposer
des opposants jeu politique et on
utilise de plus en plus souvent l'espace
cybernétique la russie et devient
souvent cible de ces attaques
en 2020 on a enregistré plus de 120000
attaque cybernétique contre les yeux de
notre infrastructure sensible la majeure
partie de ces attaques et ont été
manipulés depuis le territoire américain
des pays bas ils visaient les ans pour
soi les infrastructures de l'industrie
militaire de la santé du transport
d'administration des sciences et
d'éducation de notre fille en même temps
la russie est régulièrement et sans
fondement est accusé d'avoir organisé
des attaques cybernétiques contre des
états occidentaux et tout ça en même
temps que c'était l'occident et
notamment le temps a déclaré l'espace
cybernétique en champ de bataille à rl
la russie et continue de déclarer la
nécessité de prendre ses responsabilités
dans l'espace cybernétique élaborer des
documents des bases qui serait utilisé
pour créer des mécanismes transparents
dans quête des incidents dans le milieu
cybernétique
nous croyons nécessaire la coopération
dépolitiser de tous les pays aaa pour
créer un cadre légal pour la gestion du
domaine cybernétique ce travail doit
être réalisée elle de façon inclusive et
transparente encore dinan d'activité
avec un tour dénoncé cette ce travail
avec les organisations religieuses
régionales comme à l'organisation de ce
qui est des déchets ngayène
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective et le communauté des états
indépendants et autres au fur et à
mesure que les technologies
d'information informatique et pénètre
dans tous les milieux y elles deviennent
non facteur important de la stabilité
stratégique
ce vecteur fait aussi le dirigeant notre
travail continue à la russie a déjà
proposé d'organiser on se met des
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu pour engendrer en
discussion en direct des leaders sur le
principe de règlement des différends
internationaux pour trouver des voies et
des solutions des problèmes existants et
ce qui est important c'est qu'il faut
déterminer les paramètres de l'accord de
la coexistence pour éviter un conflit
nucléaire ou en conflit avec la
participation des états détenteurs
d'armes nucléaires on voit déjà des
fruits d'intro position
on peut citer la prolongation du du
traité start sur la limitation des armes
offensives stratégiques heures la
déclaration commune des présidents russe
et
américain en cours sur la poursuite du
dialogue assez comme ça qu'une eau
appelons le monde entier en déclarant
notre volonté à travailler ensemble sur
pour régler ces problèmes vitaux en même
temps la solution efficace des problèmes
de la stabilité stratégique reste
impossible sans un dialogue entre les
états et 100 des mécanismes de
régulation des conflits ono propos sont
justifiées par nos actes dans les
régions au mois de novembre de l'année
passée à une grâce aux efforts
diplomatiques de la russie et grâce à
usage des forces de maintien de la paix
russes aux massues apaiser les
belligérants et arrive technique combats
sanglants haut-karabakh notre pays
participe à un règlement d'autres sujets
comme le programme nucléaire iranien a
le règlement au au proche orient
le programme nucléaire de la péninsule
coréenne proche à la solution des
problèmes de la sécurité internationale
à la russie se base à la nécessité
d'union des des efforts de tous les
états nous sommes à persuader au format
polycentrique et à des relations
internationales vie basée à la
coexistence pacifique des états à la non
ingérence affaires intérieures des pays
se verront et l' usage des principes de
règlement politique et non pas militaire
en respect des normes du droit
international
le rôle prépondérant du
de l'organisation des nations unies nous
sommes contre des concepts unilatéraux
blazer leurs forces ces doctrines vise à
créer de nouveau de nouvelles lignes de
ces pressions et pour recevoir des
avantages que qu'un concurrentiel
injuste par certains pays alors ces
concepts ne peuvent pas contribuer à la
création d'un ordre mondial juste et est
stable
au contraire ils vont faire aggravé la
situation en renforçant la tension
la russie connaît très bien les airs et
tombez nez face à la sécurité régionale
et internationale sont présentés par la
politique des blocs le sommet de l'otan
qui vient d'avoir vu a fait preuve d'une
potentielle antirusse sans précédent et
à reconfirmer à les privations de
l'alliance pour le rôle dans gendarmes à
mondiale le k pop pour renforcer notre
défense n'a pas d'alternative
actuellement l'occident déclare souvent
que la russie est agressive et expansive
mais un longueur de l'effet de réel dans
les faits id le temps on continue à
augmenter les budgets militaires
nonobstant la chute de pb comment ans
dans le monde à plus de 6% durant la
pandémie de 2002 dans les free militaire
de l'alliance ont connu une augmentation
de 4% dans les chiffres absolus la pse g
tandis les pays de l'otan sans compter
les états unis ne dépasse les russies à
5 fois et si on compte le budget
militaire américain
ça fait un chiffre avant fois plus
importante que le budget l'un russe de
la défense
nous enregistrons au la dynamisation des
exercices et militaires après de nos
frontières dont les scénarios porte le
caractère anti russe
nous voyons refaire déployé des forces
supplémentaires près des frontières
nationales
ces actes ne sont que générer de la
tension dans les régions où la situation
politique et militaire était favorable
les paisibles
hier encore ça concerne notamment les
maires maltais et noir notre
préoccupation est si généré par
l'activité de le temps dans la zone
arctique en les faisant planter de
nouveaux sites emploi l'infrastructure
militaire à la russie continue de
déclarer la nécessité de garder leurs
tics en tant que zone de la paix de la
coopération internationale pour ça
assure le régime de l'opération
constructive dans les formats bilatéraux
et multilatéraux avec tous les états à
la base des cours des traités
internationaux et des accords
internationaux
c'est comme ça que nous allons agir en
tant que président de conseil arctique
et chers collègues j'ai parlé de
plusieurs défis et menace à la sécurité
internationale
mais nous devons pas oublier avec le
dynamisme du monde actuel on voit surgir
aujourd'hui on voit surgir les risques
qui hier encore serez prier commun
des sujets de science fiction il faut
une rejeter les les parties
l'exemple illustratif de ces nouvelles
menaces c'est la pandémie de covile 19
qui a non seulement surcharger la le
système de sécurité de santé publique et
mais a influencé la vie quotidienne des
gens en aggravant leur situation
économique et sociale en renforçant les
tensions politiques dans le monde pour
les questions de prévention de la haye
de la lutte contre le coc vite lakovic
la russie prend la position
substantielle à être restée ouverte et à
aider les pays qui le demande en leur
envoyant des médicaments et du matériel
médical
nonobstant de la situation géographique
et des dimensions ou de l'an fluence
apolitique et nous allons poursuivre
notre aide et à qui on demande la russie
n'utilisera jamais son accent à défendre
politique comme c'est le cas
malheureusement pour certains pays
occidentaux pour nous nous avons encore
en priorité c'est la vie et la santé de
l'homme des gens nonobstant leur opinion
politique et religion ou couleur de peau
owens met tout libye ont de l'importance
les menaces actuelles au sens
épidémiologique et ne se sont pas ne
sont pas limités par la lutte contre la
pauvreté 19
on voit les indices qui démontre que les
agents nocives a peut être utilisé à des
hommes politiques et militaires on voit
on assiste à une renaissance de la
menace d'utilisation d'armes biologiques
la communauté internationale doit prêter
attention à la coïncidence des noyaux d
des explosions des maladies contagieuses
avec les emplacements des laboratoires
étrangères a chargé des études et des
recherches biologiques
il va sans dire que les risques
biologiques ne sont pas seuls à générer
de nouvelles menaces qui peuvent tout
prochainement à prendre le premier plan
des préoccupations de la communauté
internationale
non non n'oublions pas les changements
climatiques et qui d'ici une centaine
d'années que même provoquer des
catastrophes et des crises inouïe qui
rejetterait le développement de
l'humanité et des dizaines d'années au
passé sans prendre en compte cet effet
ont fait pas dresser les pronostics pour
à long terme même à moyen terme le
développement massif des technologies a
lancé les gens' artificiers la biologie
synthétique qui tout ça est maintenant
et ray
ecotidien on voit mettant les tentatives
d'utiliser ses innovations aux intérêts
de la lutte entre les ita faisons d'en
faire des outils de création et non pas
de destruction en les mettant sous le
contrôle de la communauté internationale
chers collègues je viens d'énumérer
certains défis certaine menace à la
sécurité internationale
sans les solutions efficaces de ces
problèmes l'humanité aura du mal à faire
sont pas vers l'avenir prospère mais en
seul pays isolé ni même une réunion des
pays ne peut pas résoudre ce problème à
cela la pandémie a démontré que le monde
est en taulier
personne ne sera s'isoler de ses voisins
pour ne pas à pour se protéger contre
les menaces actuelles en se basant notre
expérience c'est que l'air ne proposons
à tous les acteurs intéressés ensemble
nous simples de krynn de stabilité
globale sur le concept est tout à fait
simple dialogue au lieu d'acquisition la
coopération au lieu de confrontation un
bon volonté contre l'égoïsme à
l'ouverture contre le double poids deux
mesures je suis persuadé que le
préoccupations d'une pays sont communes
et l'élaboration des réponses communes
aux défis d'actualité tout à fait
faisable
nous vous appelons à oeuvrer ensemble en
fédérant nos efforts pour assurer le
développement durable de notre
civilisation je vous remercie de votre
attention est donnée aux ministres des
affaires étrangères de la fédération de
russie sergueï lavrov
sergueï lavrov bermejo ce pas mesdames
et messieurs co la guerre pour moi c'est
un grand honneur d'intervenir encore un
fois au cours de la conférence de moscou
sur la sécurité internationale organisée
par le ministère de la défense de la
fédération de russie
et cette extrême un bien en fait que nos
collègues et d'autres pays étrangers
sont plus ont pu venir malgré la
situation sanitaire
ce qui démontre l'intérêt commun de
compte fait halak au g20 des intérêts
pour assainir la situation sur la rn
nationale est pour trouver les réponses
aux défis du temps contemporains et je
suis sûr que le haut niveau de
représentation va favoriser cette
recherche il ya 80 ans le 22 juin 1941
notre patrie a été attaqué par
l'allemagne nazi d'hitler qui est
aveugle l'époque pratiquement envoyer
toute l'europe et les tragédies de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
c'est un gros rappel illustres qui
démontre le résultat si on oublie les
leçons du passé surtout si on a le sens
de la primauté personnel les grâce aux
efforts personnels et surtout des
sacrifices de l'union soviétique on a
réussi à exterminer le nazisme et sauver
notre civilisation de la destruction et
pendant cette époque les un membre de la
coalition anti hitler ont démontré leur
solidarité et ils se sont réunis très
vite pour ce faire la réponse aux
agresseurs et déjà le oui je vais en
le premier ministre britannique monsieur
churchill l'a mentionné déjà la bonne
volonté et la bonne résistance de la
main soviétique à l' attaque non
provoquée des nazis et surtout il dit il
comprenait déjà le courage des soldats
soviétiques
malgré le fait que monsieur churchill
prévoyez de faire avec notre petit après
la deuxième guerre mondiale
mais on peut trouver les résultats cette
projection contre notre pays parce que
cette victoire est nette depuis
longtemps à l'époque les alliés ont
réussi à démontrer la responsabilité des
destins du monde entier pour prévenir la
guerre globale et refonder le système
international en tant que pire en violet
qui a résulté en organisation des
nations unies et le travail commun au
sein de cette organisation pendant 75
ans protègent du monde de nouveaux
conflits à l'échelle planétaire pour
assurer la stabilité globale et y
compris dans les conditions des
relations complexes entre les puissances
leader et bien sûr les litiges naturel
entre elles malheureusement ces
dernières années ont montré que
certaines capitales occidentales
dirigé par washington ils ont décidé de
suivre de suivre le cap visant à
détruire le rôle les deux de l'onu en le
remplaçant par leur propre ordre basé
sur leurs propres règles en dehors des
relations basées sur cette approche
universelle
nous voyons l'apparition de nouvelles
les coalitions qu'ils essayent de se
faire avoir
23 d'agir au nom du monde entier surtout
pas remis
lisin stars les plus illustres
j'aimerais est cité le projet qui
s'appelle l'alliance pour le
multilatéralisme organisé par paris et
berlin et surtout le sommet de la
démocratie sous l'égide de washington
mais tous ces projets sont réalisés
malgré les tentatives y est les règles
qui se trouve à la base du
fonctionnement de l'onu
si on tenir compte de la le payons des
impôts posez évidemment ce n'est pas
nécessaire de rajouter que cette
approche similaire ou une petit groupe
de pays comme j'ai déjà dix se déclarent
les mastères des destins du monde entier
en sapin les principes de l'égalité du
travail comment basé sur la charte de
l'onu
évidemment ça ne favorise pas du tout
une recherche efficace de réponse aux
problèmes et défis existants et surtout
sa green de nouvelles lignes de
divisions
on voit comment cette conscience de bloc
est imposé surtout dans les régions de
l'asie du pacifique doit être libre de
jeu politique surtout vu son rôle en
tant que moteur de l'économie nationale
aujourd'hui
le japon l'australie et les états unis
avec le soutien de l'otan'' qui
considèrent et qui se considère en tant
qu organisation avec une mission globale
la stratégie 1-2 pacifique et qui vise à
réduire le rôle de l'ancien afin de
reformater pour assurent la dissuasion
de la chine et assure l'isolation du
dollar us ci est un plus en se basant
sur la doctrine de monroe et essaie
d'imposer des règles de vie pour
l'amérique latine
surtout ce qui explique les sanctions
contre le coup bas par exemple hier
encore pour l'assemblée générale de
l'onu a pratiquement à l'unanimité voté
pour la levée de cet embargo
sauf deux pays y compris les états unis
voté contre et nous voyons toujours une
pression continue contre vénissieux là
pour chasser à lille dirigeants du
pouvoir existant aujourd'hui les
émissaires américains en afrique et les
représentants officiels de
l'administration américaine lors des
visites officielles appellent leurs
partenaires ce ne pas coopérer avec l
est russie avec la république populaire
de chine en disant que la russie et la
chine ne vont que protéger leurs propres
intérêts en afrique et c'est juste
l'occident dans l'assemblée et
washington en particulier devraient
soutenir les efforts du continent noir
en plus nous voyons situation de leurs
aux du pont de vue de la stabilité
stratégique surtout le retrait
unilatéral de washington du traité inf
et en plus nous avons été surpris par
l'absence de l'érection des états
occidentaux par rapport à la proposition
avancée par le président russe messieurs
vladimir poutine qui avait proposé à
l'époque de prévoir notre thé tea
l'équidé les missiles de portée
intermédiaire j'aimerais souligner
encore une fois que nos actions viseront
à assurer la stabilité et la sécurité de
la russie de ses alliés
pratiquement pendant 30 ans le traité
sur le ciel ouvert à aider
aux états membres de se comprendre et
surtout dans ce contexte le retrait des
états unis le retrait encore une fois
unilatérale de ce traité a violé ses
vermont l'équilibré des intérêts en
mettant notre pays en position
il n'est qu'il aimerait évidemment
c'était plus du tout logique de conduits
pour notre pays de rester en tant que
état membre de se traiter en plus mais
ce qui me frappe surtout c'est la
réaction de la part de l'otan et de
l'union européenne par rapport à notre
pas tout à fait logique qui avait appelé
moscou de ne pas détruire ce traité à
noblian la décision finale de washington
de se retirer en tant que les raisons de
base de la crise actuelle est très
souvent l'occident on met le fait qu'il
avait manqué sévèrement ses engagements
résultant du traité sur le silo vers un
fermont pour la russie à la majorité au
dessus de l'europe et du canada et de la
france est et nous avons été surpris
aussi
en regardant les documents du dernier
sommet de l'automne qui augmente les
tensions en europe
le dernier sommet que je viens de
mentionner l'alliance a démontré un
point fois son incapacité de se retirer
de la réalité qu'elle avait fait monter
elle même et dans ce contexte il prévoit
un coin fois des actions agressives de
la russie mais nous n'avions pas
atteindre quelque chose de nouveau parce
que nous sommes toujours ouverts au
dialogue sincère et ouvert
professionnelle en se basant sur nos
propositions concrètes qui visent à
réduire la menace
un militaire sur toute la ligne c'est de
contact entre la russie et le tanner qui
reste déjà sur la table depuis deux ans
mais quand même il trouve pas la réponse
pense qu'aujourd'hui le temps ne veut
pas du tout communiquer avec nous en
utilisant les voies militaires
évidemment toute tentative d' assainir
la situation dans la région atlantique
sont en face à la politique des
autorités ukrainiennes qui au fond tout
de leur mieux pour ne pas respecter les
accords de mise que ça respecter le
droit international de lettres ana
j'aimerais m'adresser un grand four au
pouvoir des états occident de d'assurer
une influence sur leurs subordonnés à
kiev et d'arrêter les attaques contre
les russes et d'autres minorités
ethniques et je pense qu'il ya une bonne
volonté est là disponibles pour le
comprenez on peut trouver des bonnes
solutions dont une bon exemple de la
résolution des problèmes dans le cadre
de la stabilité internationale qui a été
donné par l'administration américaine et
fille a démontré sa bonne volonté de
reconduire le nouveau start pour cinq
ans à venir ce qui a donné l'espoir de
continuer le dialogue sur le contrôle
des systèmes d'armes au futur et surtout
le soutien est le maintien de la
stabilité stratégique on en parle dans
la déclaration commune
ici ni par les présidents russe et
américain à genève à 16 le 16 juin
dernier et qui ont démontré le respect
des principes à ce qu'il n'y a pas de
vainqueur
il n'y a pas de gagnant dans la guerre
nucléaire et nous partons du principe
qu'il faut mettre tous les efforts et
sur l'axé bilatérales russo américain
qui doit en résulter un nouvelle
équation de sécurité qui couvrirait tous
les pasteurs qui ont un impact sur la
stabilité stratégique dont en parlant
des armements conventionnels et
nucléaires d'attaqué et de défense en
parlant d'autres problèmes dans le
domaine des armes
nbc vient aussi on a un problème et je
concernant l'arrêt et le non respect des
conventions sur à l'heure la disparition
des armes chimiques aussi bien que de la
charte de la médiation de la disparition
des armes chimiques
parce qu'ils utilisent le secrétariat de
cette organisation en tant que outil de
pression contre les régimes défavorable
ce qu'ils essaient de faire est
d'utiliser contre la république et arabe
de syrie un autre outil dans ce domaine
de non prolifération des armes bcc la
bonne volonté de renforcer la convention
sur les armes biologiques et toxines ce
que nous proposons depuis des décennies
mais quand même
l'administration américaine s'évade et
ne démontre pas sa bonne volonté d'en
discuter et en pendant qu'il continue à
développer son activité biologique en se
basant sur des relations bilatérales en
créant des laboratoires biologique
autour du périmètre de la fédération de
russie
chers collègues la russie est cet homme
pouvoir eurasiatique nous sommes un
membre du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
en tant qu un des garants de la
stabilité stratégique nous faisons une
grande des contributions dans le
renforcement de la stabilité sur tous
les axes je pourrais rajouter rappeler
nos efforts visant à exterminer le
terrorisme international en syrie
surtout assurer le bon dialogue entre
les pouvoirs et les parties en
opposition pour arrêter le sang au
karabagh et pour créer les conditions
pour restaurer la vie pacifique et dans
toute la région du caucase du nord
un comptions avec les autres
coprésidents du groupe de contact de
mise pour renforcer la confiance entre
les parties y réaliser des projets
humanitaires
nous avons une participation
constructive dans le cadre de la
pacification de la situation autour du
problème iranien aussi bien tu sur la
péninsule de corée aujourd'hui nous
voyons l'apparition brutale de nouvelles
technologies dans notre vie qui amène
avec elle de nouveaux risques qu'ils
essaient de militariser l'internet pour
vraiment faire et partons nouvelle
course aux armes sur l'internet ce
qu'ils vont avoir un impact sur le
comportement des états dans le
cyberespace est globale et surtout elle
n'est pas concret d état à part un
avançant le projet de la convention
universelle pour prévenir la
cybercriminalité lors des deux dernières
sessions de l'assemblée générale de
l'onu on était vraiment largement
soutenue sur les deux axes que je ne
m'en su nous avons déjà prévu des
mécanismes de négociation qui vont
impliquer tous les états qui vont
étudier ces deux projets d'importance
extrême et nous aspirons que nous
continuerons notre coopération sur la
sécurité informatique en utilisant les
voies de latéral et nous voudrions voit
un bon dialogue fructueux avec la partie
américaine sur la sécurité informatique
qui a été déjà abordé lors du sommet à
genève nous sommes convaincus que c'est
un beau moment de reprendre le dialogue
qui pourrait répondre aux réalités du
monde multi pôles pour trouver les
réponses
évidemment la responsabilité à part est
portée par les conseils de sécurité et
ses membres et ce qui est servi de la
base pour monsieur poutine notre
président qui a proposé de confirme
encore une fois les principes clefs de
communication inter étatiques pour
trouver des solutions collectives
commune face aux défis du temps qu'on te
rends compte tenu de l'évolution qui se
passe dans les affaires internationales
nous espérons organiser une rencontre
similaire au format personnel une fois
que la situation sanitaire le permettent
et j'aimerais mentionner encore une fois
que de gros changements dans le cadre de
l'ue et se réaliser et nous avons déjà
proposé une initiative de large format
andré celle à le ce pour qu'ils soient
orientés
ces principes de base d'origine de
fonctionnement basé sur le respect et le
dialogue et le respect des principes du
consensus
chers collègues afin d'arrêter et faire
face aux problèmes globaux
la russie tout à fait disponible est
ouverte à toute la coopération large
pour assurer l'implication de toutes les
parties
compte tenu du respect des principes de
fonctionnement de l'onu
évidemment nous continuerons notre
coopération étroite avec nos partenaires
avec ceux qui partagent notre approche
dans le cadre de l'union eurasienne
contenu aussi des états membres de la
nomination de coopération de shanghai
brics et et d'autres structures et
formats et avec d'autres états de l'asie
de l'afrique et de l'amérique latine
nous travaillons dans le but de réaliser
une initiative stratégique de vladimir
poutine et qui prévoit la création d'un
grand partenariat eurasiatique sur notre
continent comme heureuse ya tic mais
parce qu'il s'agit d'un périmètre
intracontinentale un impliquant tous les
états et toutes les structures de cet
espace afin d'assurer la stabilité la
sécurité et pour promouvoir les
avantages compétitifs sur le plan
économique mondiale c'est tout à fait
naturel nous sommes toujours ouverts à
notre dialogue avec nos partenaires
occidentaux mais à condition du respect
mutuel de l'égalité en droit et dans la
recherche de l'équilibré et du respect
des intérêts bilatéraux sans utiliser
des équipes atome surtout avancée contre
la russie est ce que l'occident est
celle utilisée dans les relations contre
eux nous avons tous fait nos études à
l'école
nos professeurs ont déjà fait de
remarque ici les comportements des
vielles c'est pour ça que je vous
souhaite la tout beau tout cela
prospecter et merci beaucoup de votre
attention
serghini schumacher le micro et aux
directeurs de service de renseignement
extérieur sergueï narychkine
chers collègues cher participants de la
conférence à partir de notre guerrier
rencontre en 2019
la situation internationale ne cesse de
s'aggraver
les défis traditionnels à la sécurité
internationales se sont multipliées en y
rajoutant la pandémie de quelques huit
des dix neuf qui a fortement frappé la
santé psychique et physique et de
l'humanité important préjudice au
système économique mondiale en
provoquant des crises politiques
internes dans plusieurs pays du monde
crise de coronavirus c'était une vraie
épreuve pour les gens et pour les
systèmes nationaux de gestion et de
développement
en même temps il faut avouer que la
crise des accords ni virus a pris bien
des vulgaires les points sensibles non
seulement l'organisme en mai à l'ordre
mondial actuel la fragilité des
institutions internationales des normes
et des règles intangibles liées encore
aider venu aussi évidente que leur
assainissement et renforcement est resté
imminente ce qui est du passé c'est du
passé maintenant il faut lui nouveau la
pandémie a démontré une crise profonde
de la globalisation mondialisation
occidental on a vu que les institutions
au global
un supra nationales et des organisations
internationales sont moins forts forte
qu le et moins rapide à prendre des
décisions anti crise qu en gouvernement
national la communauté internationale se
disant 1 s'est rendue une construction
illusoire en s'abstenant de lutter
contre cette maladie perte id les pays
occidentaux qui aime autant pour clamer
leur humanisme ont bloqué pendant
l'assemblée générale de l'onu la
résolution proposée par la russie visant
le refus des sanctions pendant la
pandémie
cet esprit de blocs et ses oeillères
idéologiques ont de nouveau pris le
dessus du bon raisonnement et la
solidarité
euratlantique a pesé plus lourd sur la
solidarité humaine et les valeurs à une
manie terre il est évident que la
pandémie de cornet virus restent eux ce
n'est pas une seule épreuve pour forcer
les acteurs internationaux à agir pour
le bien être collectif
aujourd'hui nous faisons face en nombre
accru des défis dans la lgv est efficace
contre contribuera à la survie de
l'humanité
les la vie quotidienne à est de plus en
plus de digitaliser et virtualisés ce
qui existe
j'ai la permission du nouveau méthodes
de nouvelles méthodes de la lutte contre
la criminalité cybernétique
ça exige l'élaboration des règles
transparentes et claire de comportement
dans l'espace cybernétique les problèmes
globaux économiques y compris la famine
et les flux migratoires sont de plus en
plus importante
la communauté internationale pourrait
proposer des moyens efficaces et
tangibles de résoudre ces problèmes mais
a encore une fois ces questions sont
posées qui ne trouvent pas de réponses à
de la part de certains pays
il s'agit des a's aspects moraux et
éthiques et des usages des robots de
langeais neri biologique et de
l'intelligence artificielle
sans compter le fait que ça se passe au
contexte de dégradation du système dit
de la stabilité stratégique et le
déchiffrement du système de contrôle des
armements des offres en show surgissent
sur la carte du monde de plus en plus
souvent et aucun conflit régional lequel
n'a pas encore été éradiquée reçu lui le
russe
le rude prix des amériques en de
l'afghanistan ont fait en exemple de
plus or pour personne et non plus pour
les américains ce n'est pas en secret
que l'objectif de la paix civile dans le
pays et la sud et les questions de
sécurité dans le pays
c'est qu'ils seront n'ont pas été
résolus on se pose la question à quoi çà
service et 20 ans de la guerre en fonte
des qui a fait autant des victimes
on est venu on a vu et on a laissé des
traces
comme l'a dit l'un des héros de roman de
michael schalk off ils ont lutté pour la
patrie
la complicité de la situation actuelle
exige des puissances de changer leur
politique et pour se rendre près à l'air
peut rechercher d équilibre des intérêts
des acteurs au lieu du coin ont des
pleurs que l'occident à ses forces à
faire diviser notre monde
multidimensionnelle à deux camps
artificielle en soi disant qu'en
démocratique est en soi disant qu'en
autoritaire en mettant il les étiquettes
sur la russie la chine et les ânes même
sur ses alliés de l'otan la turquie et
parfois à la pologne elle les états unis
et d'autres soi-disant idole de la
démocratie libérale ses forces à ne pas
remarquer que eux mêmes deviennent
rapidement des régimes a liberal
totalitaire c'est pas une erreur
totalitaire libéraux à mon point de vue
aux états unis et dans certains pays aux
occidentaux
on voit tout et en dise de la dictature
totalitaire selon zbigniew zielinski
regarder on à l'idéologie la monopole
des mass médias le caractère policier de
l'état l'an change habilités des élites
oligarchiques mêmes l'économie de
planning si on envisage le caractère
illégal des sanctions imposées par le
temps c'est une situation presque
absurde qui nous fait faire une allusion
à la situation de
l'ex union soviétique les dernières
années de son existence
l'occident cependant successivement
contre les mêmes actes qu'il réalise
dans sa politique antérieure
les gaffes américains propriétaires des
réseaux sociaux et des sites vidéo bloc
et facilement les comptes dont les
propriétaires ne s'inscrivent pas dans
leur politique
même à 30 a été bloqué nonobstant que 75
pour cent millions de citoyens
américains ont voté pour lui
twitter a bloqué des centaines de
milliers d acompte de haut
venus de russie de la même politique et
réalisé par youtube et twitter
mais ce n'est que le début si on le
compare avec la proposition des experts
de l'institut de l'université de
stanford qui vise à créer en groupe avec
la participation des représentants des
gaffes à des politiciens pour lutter
contre l'oxydation et pour former le
discours correct soit disant le chef de
ce groupe doit devenir en droit de les
réaliser
c'est le ministère de la vérité aussi
bien décrit par orwell l'occident se
déclare tout dit sur tous les toits
comme moi le partisan de démocratie est
lui même et n'arrive pas à mettre fin en
a passé colonial et raciste
les puissances continentales ont
commencé à assumer leurs péchés du passé
mais ensuite
à et l'on changé d'opinion d'après eux
c'est le manque de tolérance dans non
blancs ogi le problème essentiel et nous
voyons les orions démenti en doller dans
des pays occidentaux qui sont orientés à
rechercher des extrémistes en terme et
on compte parmi ses soi-disant explique
extrémistes en berne tous ceux qui ne
sont pas présentes ou dias tu as ces
expériences à sion néolibérale avec
l'identité humaine
en contrepoids robes ce2 aux valeurs
occidentales la russie et la majeure
partie des pays orientale nos protégeons
les valeurs universelles le respect aux
parents le souci est d pour des enfants
le lien avec les pâtes riz avec
l'endroit où l'homme est né à et le
droit des peuples ea au développement à
en dépendant avec ses différences des
voleurs et des approches les problèmes
sont nombreux entre la russie et
l'occident qui sont aussi aggravée par
des tentatives entreprises par les états
unis et les pays de l'union européenne à
qui a cessé de justifier toutes sortes
des problèmes par des soi-disant
activités néfastes de la russie c'est
pas nouveau pour les russies détruit
cible des accusations mal fondée pendant
d
l'idée ni de notre histoire la russie et
le peuple russe a déjà informé les
réponses valables à cette sorte de
comportement à irresponsable c'est le
renforcement du potentiel des défenses
et le renforcement de l'autosuffisance
économique et financière et scientifique
et la pandémie de lakovic 19 heures à
pouvait que les rues si on mesure de
faire face à des défis les plus
importants du monde contemporain même
étant cible des sanctions de la part des
états en d2 les états occidentaux
nous avons beaucoup de pays alliés c'est
en partie des différentes unions
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai brics à l'organisation du
traité de sécurité collective et autres
nous avons des accords bilatéraux avec
la chine avec land ce qui renforce une
façon considérable le potentiel
économique et jeu politique de notre
pays en contribuant largement à assurer
à la stabilité et eurasiatique et
assurer les équilibres stratégiques et
des foursomes dans le monde
nous restons ouverts au dialogue avec
eux tout le monde et si l'occident est
en mesure développer notre volonté s'il
est encore à ce sans citer de cet esprit
de dialogue qui a été démontrée lors de
sommets de genève
ça reste une question il faut arrêté de
dessiner des
ligne de séparation pour recommencer le
dialogue
il entend résoudre de vrais problèmes à
l'échelle mondiale le monde s'habitue
peu à vivre à l'absence du niehs
hégémonie évidemment pour former un
monde multipolaire
c'est un travail que l'on est épineux
les défis c'est parce qu'ils ne manquent
mais je suis persuadé que les leaders
mondiaux ont assez de courage et de
responsabilité pour surmonter ces
obstacles je vous remercie de votre
attention mesdames et messieurs ont fait
une pause technique et vous êtes priés
de bien vouloir rester sur place